the german pavilion at Expo 2015 in
Milan its theme is field of ideas and
presents concepts about how to tackle
the problem of feeding the world euromax
reporter Hendrik villing was one of the
first visitors to take a look around the
pavilion some 3 million people are
expected to pass through its doors in
the coming six months so now I'm excited
about the exhibition in the German
pavilion and how Germany's
interpretation of this year's Expo team
feeding the planet energy for life
that's the central theme of Expo 2015
nutrition sustainability and green
energy are key issues the visitors
receive a seed board when they enter the
pavilion this simple piece of cardboard
helps them explore the various stations
when opened in certain areas the seed
board lets you see projected films or
info hendrik controls the action by
tipping the board or moving it up and
down the specialized technology
recognizes the outlines of the board and
ensures the content is projected onto
just the right spot
so I'm pretty impressed by this seat
board actually because it's just a piece
of paper but it works really really well
in the first part of the exhibition
visitors learn about the role water
earth & climate play in food production
hendrik tries out things on his own
communicates with other visitors on the
roof
or uses his seed board and he meets the
brains behind this interactive
exhibition hater redlin yeah the other
students the VIP friends Izzy Sherman
the nicest thing would be for you to be
infected with the joy we had in
developing this um yeah if and to take
away not just the atmosphere but also a
better understanding of the theme of
this Expo yeah 15 fess up to steal each
area profiles actual projects like the
gotchas laban gene bank which collects
the seeds of endangered plant species
it's a showcase for biodiversity with
his seed board Hendrick learns what
plants are under threat a whole room is
devoted to food what do we eat how will
we feed ourselves in the future and how
is food grown this room inspires our
reporter to plant some lettuce on the
balcony his tour ends with a show here
to Hendrick plays an active role he
takes a trip through Germany from abby's
perspective with sound effects provided
by two musicians
creative ideas are to be found not only
in but also on the pavilion hendrik
notices the solar panels printed on the
membrane roofs this innovation produces
enough electricity to power to
households yigit's tome DS a lot saying
this is about showing the solar cells
creating an exhibit in presenting an
application that inspires architects and
designers to pick up on this technology
and perpetuated so I've invited to a few
after his tour of the German pavilion
it's time for Hendrik to relax and enjoy
the view over the expo grounds so it was
really interesting to visit the German
pavilion today either year on the roof
and in the exhibition downstairs and it
made me little bit proud to see how the
Germans handle the topics nutrition and
sustainability the German pavilion at
Expo 2015 invites visitors to
participate and that's the first step
towards meeting the challenge of feeding
the planet in the future